- [Instructor] We are asked,
What is the average rate of
change of the function f,
and this function is f up here,
this is the definition
of it, over the interval
from negative two to three,
and it's a closed interval
because they put these brackets around it
instead of parentheses,
so that means it includes
both of these boundaries.
Pause this video and see if
you can work through that.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
So there's a couple of ways
that we can conceptualize
average rate of change of a function.
One way to think about it is
it's our change in the
value of our function
divided by our change in x,
or it's our change in
the value of our function
per x on average.
So you can view it as change
in the value of the function,
divided by your change in x.
If you say that y is equal to f of x,
you could also express it as change in y
over change in x.
On average, how much
does the function change
per unit change in x on average?
And we could do this with a table,
or we could try to
conceptualize it visually.
Let's just do this one with a table,
and then we'll try to
connect the dots a little bit
with a visual.
So if we have x here, and
then if we have y is equal to
f of x right over here, when
x is equal to negative two,
what is y going to be equal to,
or what is f of negative two?
Well, let's see.
f of, so why is equal
to f of negative two,
which is going to be
equal to negative eight,
that's negative two to the third power,
minus four times negative two,
so that's minus negative
eight, so that's plus eight.
That equals zero.
And then when x is equal to three,
I'm going to the right
end of that interval.
Well, now y is equal to f of three,
which is equal to 27,
three to the third power,
minus four times three, minus
12, which is equal to 15.
So what is our change in y
over our change in x over this interval?
Well, our y went from zero to 15,
so we have an increase of 15 in y.
And what was our change in x?
Well, we went from negative
two to positive three,
so we had a plus five change in x.
So our change in x is plus five,
and so our average rate of change with y
with respect to x, or the
rate of change of our function
with respect to x, over the interval,
is going to be equal to three.
If you wanted to think
about this visually,
I could try to sketch this.
So this is the x-axis, the y-axis,
and our function does something like this.
So at x equals negative
two, f of x is zero,
and then it goes up, and
then it comes back down,
and then it does something like this,
it does something like this, and it does,
and it was going before this,
and so the interval that we care about,
where we're going from
negative two to three,
which is right about there.
So that's x equals negative
two to x equals three,
and so what we want to do, at
the left end of the interval,
our function is equal to
zero, so we're at this point,
right over there, I'll
do this in a new color,
at this point, right over there,
and at the right end of our function,
f of three is 15, so we
are up here someplace.
Let me connect the curve a little bit.
We are going to be up there.
And so when we're thinking
about the average rate of change
over this interval, we're
really thinking about
the slope of the line that
connects these two points.
So the line that connects these two points
looks something like this.
And we're just calculating
what is our change in y,
which is going to be
this, our change in y,
and we see that the value of our function
increased by 15, divided
by our change in x.
So this right over here
is our change in x,
which we see went from
negative two to three.
That's going to be equal to five.
So that's all we're doing
when we're thinking about
the average rate of change.